[Musica]
[Applauso]
questa è una di quelle storie dove il
punto di partenza è il punto di arrivo è
sempre lo stesso ma posso assicurarvi
che non sono stato fermo tutto cominciò
nel 2013 quando veramente decisi di
partire torino mi stava un po stretta
stavo facendo le stesse cose da troppo
tempo avevo bisogno di fare nuove
esperienze e mi stavo un po avvitando su
me stesso la spinta fu cercare di
raggiungere una persona cara questa
persona cara si trovava in nepal
da musicista avevo voglia quasi il
bisogno di unire l'esperienza del
viaggio alla mia grande passione mi
sembrerà strano ma banalmente una notte
digitali su google kathmandu e jazz e
walk kathmandu jazz conservatori il
conservatorio di kathmandu scrissi
immediatamente mi risposerò altrettanto
immediatamente dopo circa una settimana
mi offrirono quattro mesi di contratto
si sa il nepal non è una una di quelle
nazioni ricche e quindi il contratto non
prevedeva purtroppo la copertura delle
spese dei viaggi internazionali
dall'italia
così decisi di scrivere all'istituto di
cultura italiano più vicino a nuova
delhi spiegandogli la situazione
beh con mia grande sorpresa e senza
contatti diretti
mi offrirono dei concerti in india con i
quali avrei potuto coprire le spese di
viaggio e godere di un fondo per vivere
al meglio l'esperienza nel paese
sono partito i concerti sono andati bene
i contatti sono aumentati
la ruota ha cominciato a girare sono
stati tre anni magnifici di viaggio e
ecco un piccolo assaggio
[Musica]
bene
e perché
[Musica]
[Applauso]
esperienza da sassofonista globe trotter
mi ha cambiato radicalmente la vita ho
visto realtà in crescita la cina l'india
e l'australia dove l'italianità è un
valore aggiunto di default che ho
cercato di usare al meglio
ho anche ricevuto ottime proposte di
lavoro ben retribuite la insegnante o la
performer ma sono tornato ho deciso di
tornare dopo anni passati ad assorbire
suoni culture colori ho sentito la
necessità di sereno un posto che fosse
casa dove poter buttare fuori attraverso
la musica
tutto quello che avevo vissuto charlie
parker grande sassofonista disse la
musica e la tua esperienza i tuoi
pensieri e la tua saggezza
se non vivi la musica non verrà mai
fuori dal tuo strumento nel mio caso la
storia di sassofonista verrà il
viaggiatore verrà raccontata nel mio
terzo album da solista che attualmente
in produzione un album che avrà
atmosfere elettroniche improvvisazioni e
contaminazioni culturali
collaborerò con artisti locali e artisti
incontrati all'estero un percussionista
senegalese la rapper cinese il cantante
di musica classica indiana torino è casa
e questo è il miglior posto per farlo
torino ha grandi potenzialità e sta
diventando sempre più città
internazionale ci sono artisti di ottimo
livello con cui collaborare e con cui
confrontarsi
c'è anche il rovescio della medaglia c'è
da dire che solo in città
nel mio piccolo so che ci sono 20 piu o
meno sassofonisti bravissimi
professionisti
proprio per questo penso sia necessario
lavorare non tanto sul essere più bravi
tecnicamente degli altri ma sulla
propria unicità sulla propria
autenticità
bisogna scavare dentro se stessi per
sentire la propria voce e per scoprire
il proprio suono ormai la bellezza del
mix delle culture sta diventando un must
dei miei progetti
oltre al disco solista o una band con
cui amo suonare formata da tre musicisti
senegalesi e due musicisti italiani
tutti residenti a torino
la band si chiama ancora bit ora con
l'acca
e la cosa è un'arpa tradizionale
dell'africa occidentale
mi piace condividere l'esperienza di
sassofonista viaggiatore e spiegare come
sono riuscito a suonare in festival
ambascia ambasciate istituti di cultura
a coloro che hanno voglia di buttarsi
come ho fatto io senza management senza
agenzie di organizzazione eventi solo
con le mie forze
molti mi chiedono dei piccoli ma
importanti consigli su cose che ho
imparato sul campo
beh quello che posso dire che è
viaggiare da solo con uno strumento in
spalla con la propria passione per mesi
in paesi così diversi dal nostro
richiede coraggio richiede capacità
organizzativa e capacità improvvisativa
risolvere i problemi e le necessità in
tempi rapidi cercare le scintille
sicuramente un'esperienza che ti fa
crescere come persona torino è casa mia
e la mia base ma soprattutto per un
mestiere come il mio è necessario
sapersi muovere saper partire se per
tornare se per rimanere aspettare saper
parte ripartire e tornare ancora si
dalla mia esperienza posso dire che il
posto che stavo cercando e dentro di me
e dentro il mio strumento il brano che
voglio suonarvi è un brano composto tre
anni fa prima della partenza per il
nepal
un brano che poi mi ha portato molta
fortuna con cui ho aperto i principali
concerti di tutti i tour
il brano si chiama chromatic moon ed è
un grande onore per me poter vero
suonare oggi grazie e buon ascolto
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no
sarà
è
no
gatta
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no
bene
[Musica]
[Applauso]